the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
i am very excited to be able to bring
all of you this video because today i
will be discussing something that has
fascinated me ever since i was made
aware of it many years ago
in this video we will take an inside
look at the disastrous
original unaired pilot episode of game
of thrones
now this is something i have discussed
before but new information
continues to get released now that game
of thrones is over
i do however realize that some of you
may think the info is boring
but i am always very interested in
learning any new details about this
mysterious first episode
for those of you that might not know
game of thrones was actually very close
to getting cancelled before it ever
became an official series on hbo
now according to legend the original
unaired first episode looks nothing like
the first episode we saw
nearly a decade ago for many years we
have heard about some of the issues dan
and dave had when they were making this
first episode
it was so bad only a handful of their
friends and executives from hbo have
seen it
i've been hearing about this episode for
so long i would gladly hand over a large
amount of money just to be able to get a
glimpse of this thing
i bet it is fantastic in the worst kind
of ways
unfortunately we may never actually see
this episode on film
but thankfully some new information has
been brought to light
thanks to james hibbard at
entertainmentweekly james is actually
releasing a book titled
fire cannot kill a dragon game of
thrones and the official
untold story of the epic series james
does seem to have a great relationship
with everyone at hbo who worked on game
of thrones because he always had the
behind the scenes exclusives
right before every new season whatever
one day i hope he's able to get us the
entire episode because like i said
i am dying to watch it but for now let
me show you some of the new details that
will be included in his new book
this will be the first ever behind the
scenes account of what happened during
the making of game of thrones from start
to finish
alright so the article from
entertainmentweekly says the following
picks up midway through the original
pilot's production in 2009
first-time showrunners david benioff and
dan weiss had struggled for four years
to get their fantasy series off the
ground
there had been an endless number of
meetings rewrites negotiations
and hiring decisions it was frightening
because it was our first time running a
production of any scale
weiss recalls and there are many many
moving parts
human and otherwise that go into any
production especially one of this size
finally the cameras were rolling in
northern ireland and morocco
but even the production's most
experienced members had never worked on
a tv series as
ambitious as what thrones was attempting
and some of the veteran actors were
getting the sense that not all was well
in westeros
now one of the things that i always
thought was crazy was that hbo allowed
dan and dave to run this show
they have even said as much themselves
they had very little experience at all
so the fact that they were given the
reins to handle something of this size
seems absolutely
insane now although i do love the first
episode they gave us
this may have been the foreshadowing for
what would happen at the end of the
series when they would no longer have
any source material to draw from
alright so now i want to get into some
of the things i have never heard before
the actor mark addie also known as
robert baratheon
said we were trying to establish the
rules and order of this new world
in the winterfell courtyard scene nobody
kneeled when the king arrived in the
first pilot
you can't play being the king you can't
display look at how powerful i am
people have to give you that by showing
subservience it has to be afforded to
you by others
in the reshoot everybody kneeled it made
a huge difference
in terms of establishing who's in charge
the actress
lena heady also known as cersei
lannister said i was looking like a
vegas showgirl in the original episode
i was wearing furs and massive hair like
a medieval dolly parton
now if you go back and read the book it
says ned stark kneels down
and he even kisses cersei lannister's
ring during robert baratheon's arrival
scene in the first episode
i have no idea why they thought it would
be a good idea not to have anyone kneel
when the king is arriving in winterfell
out of the blue
it is amazing though how those small
changes can make such big differences
and when it comes to cersei looking like
a medieval country singer
that just sounds hilarious i would love
to see at least a photo of how she
looked during
her original scene now there is actually
a photo of george rr martin from the
first episode
and by the looks of him you can get a
sense for how ridiculous some of the
characters must have looked in that
original episode
for those of you that don't know george
rr martin was an extra during dany's
wedding scene
but it was ultimately cut out of the
episode as well as crazy as he may look
at least he does look like he's having
fun let's look at what else was said
this was said by brian cogman who
started out as just an assistant on the
show
but later became one of the writers and
he actually wrote one of the better
episodes in the final season
brian said when we first shot the scene
where the starks find the direwolves
this was the version you never saw the
wonder of what a direwolf was wasn't
coming across
it did not seem important enough to the
characters and i'm little assistant
brian running around the set yelling to
anyone who would listen
these are dire wolves no one has seen
these in a million years
this is like seeing dinosaurs it's not
like finding puppies
and everyone's sort of chuckling now
this is one of the things that did annoy
me when i first read it
the fact that the actors were not taking
this scene very serious is just a
reflection of what sort
of environment they were working in now
i don't know who was in charge on this
day
i don't know if george rr martin was
there or dan and dave or only the
director
but they have to lead by example how can
the actors take things seriously if no
one else there is
you know it's kind of sad that brian
cogman who was only an assistant
at that time has to explain to everyone
how significant this moment in the story
is
you would think there would have been
side notes on each of their scripts
letting them know
hey the starks finding these direwolves
is sort of a big deal
so you might wanna you know act like it
let's look at some of the other
ridiculousness
the actor harry lloyd also known as
danny's brother viserys
said i had a different wig it was
titanium
and silver and it was shorter and a bob
looking back
it was a mistake yeah no kidding for
those of you that don't know what this
would look like if you take a look at
the screen i will show you what a bob
style haircut
looks like can you imagine viserys
wearing a wig that looks like that
there would be no way i could look at
him during a scene without busting out
laughing
thank god they decided to change it to
longer hair that would have been
horrific
the actor ian glenn also known as jorah
mormont said this
it was a bit ragged and in some ways
ill-conceived
and no one had great conviction since
the wedding was shot at night
quite a lot of money had been spent on
seeing absolutely
f all well this certainly would not be
the first time he has been in a very
expensive episode that was shot at night
that resulted in them not being able to
see anything at all
now i wonder what episode i'm referring
to
i forgot to mention when we see danny's
wedding in the show
it's during the day but in the original
first episode they had shot all those
scenes at night
george r martin said there are a couple
of stories
as a wedding gift call drogo gives
daenerys a silver horse and she rides
away
for a moment you think she's fleeing
then she turns the horse around
and leaps the horse over a big campfire
drogo is very impressed
and it starts the relationship on a good
note we tried to film that scene
we got a top stunt rider and a top horse
a silver filly but the philly would not
jump that campfire
she got close and then was like there's
fire there and would turn the other way
we tried to film it a half dozen ways so
the director goes
let's put out the fire and we'll do the
fire with cgi
they put out the fire and the horse
would still not jump the dead fire it's
a smart horse
it may not be burning now but it was
burning a little while ago
so they had to scrap that sequence which
was unfortunate
as it was a bonding moment between danny
and carl drogo
now you would think they would have
gotten another horse and attempted this
on another day
when the fire was completely out
regardless of all the issues they did
have
i still think the first episode they
gave us was amazing
however it is definitely unfortunate
when they have to cut out scenes like
this
because it's these little nuances that
make this story so great
as you all know the dothraki have a very
close relationship with their horses
now maybe not as much as the starks do
with their direwolves or the targaryens
do with their dragons
but a very close relationship
nonetheless it would have been great to
see daenerys do this in front of all the
dothraki men
especially when you consider how young
daenerys was and the fact that she
didn't have a lot of experience riding
horses
we would have been able to see called
drogo admire her for having the courage
to do this in front of everyone there
now if you remember danny and drogo's
first sex scene
then you will remember how daenerys did
not give him consent
well that's not how it happened in the
books and that's not how it happened in
the original
first episode in the original scene they
were using another actress as daenerys
targaryen
and their scene followed more closely to
the book george r martin said
their original scene was a seduction
danny and drogo don't have the same
language
danny is a little scared but also a
little excited
and drogo is being more considerate i'm
not sure why they decided to change this
they obviously had to reshoot the scene
because now they had emilia clarke as
daenerys but they
should have done it the same way george
r martin intended it to be
now i want to show you what happened
when dan and dave showed some of their
family members the original episode
this was before they made any changes
they wanted to see what others would
think of it
and i will tell you now it did not go
well david benioff said
i showed it to my brother-in-law and
sister-in-law and just sat back and
watched their reactions
you could tell by watching their faces
that they were bored
it wasn't anything they said they were
trying to be nice
dan weiss said you listen to how sharply
the pitch of somebody's voice turns up
when they tell you it's good
it's good how much higher than their
average register
is the word good that's a gauge of how
eft
you are our good was in dog whistle
territory
there were others who weren't trying to
be nice but were actually trying to be
helpful
craig mason told us you guys have a
massive problem
michael lombardo who also worked for hbo
said
there were some concerns about whether
we were getting enough wide shots
are we getting the coverage we need we
hired the best costume designer and the
best art director and shot this in
northern ireland
in morocco yet there was very little
scope i remember the quote was
we could have shot this in burbank
somebody else said
it looks like it was shot in my backyard
now that's just sad
however i do think they did a good job
at fixing it
at least in the northern scenes another
thing george r martin said was
the biggest thing was dan and dave
called me up and had the idea of
eliminating rickon
the youngest of the stark children
because he didn't do much in the first
book
i said i had important plans for him so
they kept him one confusing aspect
wasn't entirely the filmmaker's fault
they could not afford to stage any
king's landing scenes which more
firmly established the lannister family
and the reshoot
but the dialogue didn't help either the
shocking punch of jaime shutting bran
out the window seemed
nonsensical as viewers did not realize
that jaime and cersei were sibling
lovers trying to protect their
treasonous secret
the producers tried to help explain the
show's backstory by adding at
least one flashback of ned stark's
father and brother being killed by the
mad king
but that idea was later scrapped as well
because it just seemed to add to the
narrative muddiness
now you can actually see some shots from
that scene i have seen some of the
images of ned stark's brother
brandon stark laying on the floor of the
red keep
i believe some of that scene was
included in the dvd extras of the first
season or maybe some of the history and
lore
i can't remember exactly i want to show
you one more thing before i end the
video
let me show you what dan and dave said
they did to help get themselves a second
chance at making the episode
before hbo decides to cancel the series
before it even began
dan weiss said we had done a lot of soul
searching
the one thing i think we did right is we
owned all the mistakes
we did not point fingers we said we know
this isn't good
and here is what went wrong and how we
would do it differently next time
we just went down the line and i think
they got the sense that which was honest
that we weren't coming in trying to
explain why the bugs were features
we were all on the same page that where
we want to be is many levels up from
this
there was a lot of begging i think what
was clearly evident was that there was a
show here
this is why you do a pilot episode
because you're looking at what works and
what doesn't
and whether this thing has legs now once
certain things were fixed
this would be a story you can tell over
many episodes that keeps moving
with characters that keep evolving but
not so fast that you run out of story
whoa whoa hold the f up let me read that
last sentence to you one more time
once certain things were fixed this
would be a story you can tell over
many episodes that keeps moving with
characters that keep evolving
but not so fast that you run at a story
why is it ending i i don't know ask dave
and dan when they come through
um we could have gone to 11 12
13 season you wanted it to keep going
well it you know if you've read my
novels
you know there was enough material for
for more seasons they made certain cuts
[Music]
[Music]
you